we're still continuing to understand the
fundamental idea of what is a function
right now last time we introduced the
idea of like what's the deuce in a
function like say that and just any kind
of random equation that gives us a graph
so for example one of the not functions
that we had a look at was this guy what
kind of shape is it it's a circle and
the reason it is not he's my circle the
reason it is not a function is because
you can answer this in two ways and you
want to throw something at me why is it
that this is not a function Brian what's
up with you okay so one of the ways that
you could say it is if you take not just
a straight line by the way because this
is also straight line but it's it's a
vertical straight line you take it and
if you move it across at different
points it intersects not once but twice
right so that's a dud that was like our
quick visual test but there was a more
technical way we said I even asked you
to write it down
ugly what wasn't very good so each input
which is an x value gives you more than
one output which is a Y value so that
was why it was no dice okay so we
explored that but what we want to do is
around that give some language and some
notation that allows us to deal with
these objects a little more easily okay
so I can't remember if this was the
exact equation we had before but it
doesn't matter what I want you just
write it down and underneath it another
color I'm going to state this in a
slightly different way I want to say
that see how Y is an output that depends
on this X input right why I can
therefore say is Y is a function of X Y
is a function of X if you supply an x
value I will tell you what the Y value
is and this language is really powerful
right I can say for instance I think I'm
you know we're having this conversation
yesterday I can say whether is a
function of and then all the things that
go into whether temperature humidity air
pressure
wind direction all that kind of thing
right those are the inputs and your
output is like ah it's a this kind of
day today it's snowing today it's
hailing whatever it is okay so why is a
function of X and what we do is to
formalize that we actually write this
slightly differently we say Y and then
in brackets we put whatever input goes
into it now this is weird
write this down but please note this is
not the usual way like the usual meaning
for when you see F for instance I wrote
you this what would that mean when you
see that number or even not even the
number like a letter a pronumeral and
then you saw X minus 1 in brackets after
that what would that normally indicate
to you it means that brackets to expand
right so usually you'd say oh that's
some a X minus a so you've treated this
as a our multiplication as a product
right which is what you're used to doing
okay this we're going to sort of like
you know in English we sometimes we use
the same word to mean two different
things like say the word this is a read
one a cleaver right it's like a big
knife so a meat cleaver to cleave is two
separate things right but it also means
to put things together which is weird
the one word two separate meanings so
here this one piece of notation it means
quite different things I know that seems
strange but it's a really really handy
and common use of this notation so if
you see this word how do you know what
tells you whether that means put
together or cut apart how could you tell
you look for the surrounding context
that tells you meaning right so in the
same way this notation you look for
surrounding context is anything around
this talking about functions it probably
means that Y is a function of X or are
they talking about some algebraic
expression they asked you to expand then
probably it means just get rid of the
brackets okay
so Y with a bracket around it X is
another way of saying
why is a function of X this particular
way and I can do this in lots of
different ways I could say or let's see
if I carried on this notation
how would you read that what's F and
what's T well F is like Y here it's the
output it's the name of the function
what's teeth teeth teeth the input it's
the thing you put into it
like X and then you get your wire your
output okay so for instance I'll just
make one up
how about this I like threes today plus
four so f are the way I read this is f
is a function of T you put in a value of
T you'll get a value for it okay so I'm
gonna run with both of these I'm gonna
use them each as an example if I said
this was our function of X then I could
say well what does this mean if I sort
of keep in this scheme right I've put a
five yeah look I've substituted an X for
five someone I'm going to do is every
time I saw an X I'm gonna replace it
with a five so you can write this with
me if it's three X minus one but I'm
thinking about X is five then it would
be three times five whoops minus 1 3
times 5 is 15 so you take my 1 you have
14 ok so I would read that as Y of 5 Y
of X F of let's try this one
how about something like say F of
negative 1 what would that mean in this
case yeah are you
perfect so everywhere Agnes or a tea he
replaced it with their negative what we
can go ahead and finish this negative 1
squared is is just positive 1 right
because the negatives cancel 3 plus 4
that's 7 okay so you can substitute
anything in you like you could even
substitute in are the pronumerals for
instance I could try let's go back to
the y1 I could say oh how about Y of hmm
a plus 7 okay figure out this for a
second instead of putting the X instead
of putting a 5 I've put an A plus 7 in
there what that means is everywhere you
saw an X before replace it with a plus
several well let's see what happens
three times a plus seven minus one okay
let's see yeah okay so this is just
brackets isn't it it's a bit funny we're
mixing it together and I know that's a
bit confusing but you'll get used to it
this is a 3a plus 21 take away 1 3 plus
2 done okay this is a weird P you can
even put other functions inside these
functions watch I could do let's do Y
and I'll do the other way around
I'll do F of Y of X huh
so what this means is everywhere I saw a
t I'm gonna put that thing is that okay
whatever that happens to be and I just
said it's that okay so it's okay it's
not that car it's not that complicated
I'm gonna go three now then I see a t so
I'm looking to write T I'm gonna write
whatever this is what what is this it's
three X minus one that's T and what what
am I supposed to do with T I was
supposed to square it like that plus
four I guess we can work this out let's
see here
9x squared what I put in the middle
oh yeah look that's a great question I
need another color to show you we go why
is it three at the front because I'm
putting it into this F object function
which has a three it has T squared and
it has plus four you see that so every
piece from the original function is here
in the new function okay does that make
sense
so three T squared three this is what T
is right now okay can you help me finish
expanding this thing what's the next
term I'd probably go I need both of
those I usually put the minus 6x in the
middle and then the plus one okay plus
four and then I just I guess I have to
expand let's see 27 that's plus three
plus four plus seven is that okay